I
there are almost 300,000 alumni that are
part of this columbia alumni association
from all 16 schools of the university
and we needed to provide a platform that
enabled Colombians to connect so our job
is to connect them with each other and
to connect them back with the university
that's the role of the CAA it's the the
organization that encompass a--'s and
surrounds all the alumni from all the
divisions of the university we all share
a bond because we went to Columbia some
of us went to different schools went to
schools uptown or whatever there is a
common experience that's in the past but
the CAA draws on that draws on whatever
affinity or affiliation people feel
based on that to build an experience in
the present
so the CAA has many events throughout
the year we try to be as creative and
innovative as we can with new events
every year but we also like to have
tradition and the most prominent is
reunions coming back to campus and
listening to faculty connecting with
your classmates connecting with your
school in the university I'm having a
good time reliving the college days
staying in carman hall and seeing old
friends and acquaintances I would say
there hasn't been a year since 1971 that
we haven't been in touch with each other
as a young alum even though we're still
in touch a lot we don't see each other
that often so we did some brunch some
bloody marys and then kind of came back
on campus and kind of started catching
up for folks here
as we talked about the Columbia lifelong
experience with many of our programs we
want to provide an intellectual
opportunity as well as a social
networking or career networking
opportunity I'm here in Barcelona as
part of a columbia alumni event it's my
very first event on any scale and so I
figured why not do it a big so this is a
four or five-day trip the type of people
that are drawn to Colombia are the type
of people that would engage in lifelong
learning and be naturally drawn to the
subject matter experts in those fields
and seek them out and so I think having
access to Dean Becker and some of the
other experts they brought in has been
just exactly what we would have wanted
and so it's it's nice to see Barcelona
through their eyes as well
friends of mine have come to art basel
in miami and i always felt left out i
wanted to come but you've come to a big
event like that you need somebody to
guide you through all of the events I'm
sure that we could not have come to
Miami and had the same access or the
same guidance had it not been for the
columbia alumni association and I give
columbia credit
this is one of my favorite events of the
year the Columbia party at Sundance I
feel like every year I come out of it
seeing people that I haven't seen in a
long time but really needing a lot of
connections and people that we have to
leave something in common and we have
they're looking out for me and I'm
looking out for them movies are
something to kind of take for granted
with all the other movies but I've never
actually spent a lot of time thinking
about how they're crafted and here at
Sundance I learned a lot about that
meaning the columbia filmmakers i live a
lot about that some of the films are
seen as we want brain has been bursting
and this event i think really connects
me and makes me feel like i am again a
part of a bigger community
as president Bollinger was saying we are
leaders Columbia is a leader in the
world and as alumni you are leaders in
your own fields benefiting from the
wonderful Columbia education and we want
today to be able to bring those links
together to link you into the world of
Columbia to use you to take Columbia
farther into the world beyond the campus
and just to solidify those relationships
we are represented as columbia alumni
from the White House to the Supreme
Court from Congress and throughout the
cabinet I feel very privileged to be a
part of this wonderful alumni body
columbia really is committed to this
kind of engagement and there are lots of
tangible examples the creation of the
columbia alumni association about six
years ago the creation of our first
alumni center on campus on 113 street on
help when you're in new york you'll come
visit us we have an alumni Welcome
Center we're very proud of that I think
a lot of you are here for the first time
in this building our alumni center the
columbia alumni center has been open for
just over two years two and a half years
and this is really your space it's the
first time probably in generations that
Columbia has had a physical place on
campus where you're absolutely welcome
to make yourself at home to hang your
hat to have a cup of coffee to use a
computer to set up your your own
wireless connection and any other
connection you care to make here so this
is your space and we hope you'll take
advantage of it the success of the CAA
has come from alumni volunteers and
alumni participation for any
organization be successful it's vital
for the leadership in ownership to come
from the members from the alumni and
that is why the ca has been so
successful and will continue to grow
I enjoy being part of the the board in
France because it allows me to wait to
sort of actually give back to school by
doing something to be able to interview
you know potential students and to
actually go out and meet the alums and
to see the diversity of people who have
graduated from different schools and and
what they're doing i think is is
interesting for me also personally this
CA brings together alumni leaders in
several different settings and most of
the time we sit around the room and chat
about their experiences as the leaders
in different regions with different
groups we share best practices we share
strategies we share what works and what
doesn't work and how we can support them
it's important for us to hear what what
we can do what the university can do
what the CAA can do to help them in
their roles I attended the Athens
meeting last year and it was a great of
great great meeting you know you know
those census meeting Columbia people
networking also the original Club
leaders work that we had there talking
about how we make class more dynamic how
to do more networking how to create more
interest in the clap and I think it was
split in this year in which we're still
in the middle of the of the meeting but
so far I think people is enjoying so
much really the Barcelona experience and
the Columbia experience
part of my mission or what I would like
to see is every alumni in some way shape
or form whether it's small or large be
connected or involved every single year
with Columbia University so we have the
CAA challenge and this year we are
asking every alum to do something new
they haven't done before go to an event
contact your roommate send in a story
forward a magazine article do one
Columbia thing you haven't done before
as an alumnus for an alumna and find out
what the alumni experience can mean to
you do one new thing be a part of this
challenge the alumni connection isn't
about a chance to reconnect with what
happened 10 or 15 or 20 years ago I mean
there is that aspect of nostalgia or
reconnection but it's really about the
fact that you still belong at columbia
and the Columbia that you belong to is
actually an incredibly exciting and
evolving and dynamic place and it's
online it's in person it's all over the
world and it's in New York City and on
campus and I think that everybody feels
at the end that they have been part of
something larger than themselves
students are students for 246 and in
some PhD situations 10 or 12 years the
people who are here and involved the
longest are the alumni they are alumni
for the remainder of their natural lives
and even into the hereafter because I'm
fairly convinced that there are alumni
who are still active though not with us
on this earth CAA is energy CAA is
adventure daa its friend the CIA is
Barcelona crazy the CAA is opportunity
so she is family the CAA is timeless the
CIA is tailor-made the CAA is
celebration the CAA is empowering the
CAA is diversity the CA is the Columbia
spirit CAA is where you wanna be
you